hey you guys are so good in this I
didn't expect it to be so emotional uh
but I do have a question David Harbor is
wearing a bowling shirt he has a comb
over he's a ghost and yet we oddly fall
in love with him how do you explain this
there's nothing sexier than a combo
nothing it's like it shows that you're a
thoughtful person as comfortable with
yourself
you know no but he's not trying to
change that he's not getting a a head
BBL he's not doing that he's living with
him he's living with it yeah that's sexy
confidence confidence I was gonna say
confidence okay well speaking of
confidence uh jihi would you be as cool
as your character if you saw a ghost
would you be laughing and recording or
would you freak out
uh I'll freak out yes definitely
flighting flight flight
um yeah there'll be a a jahi-shaped hole
in the wall I don't
moose I'm like Ray Parker Jr we don't
want no ghosts
my thing
and
um yeah I would not be not happy it's
cool
yeah that was like my favorite answer of
the day uh Anthony would you be
it depends like you know if it's Halle
Berry ghost I might have to see what's
going on there okay but if you know you
know what I mean like you gotta weigh
your options but other than that I'm out
I'm out like a Pam
I'm in you know yeah yeah like what's
happening like where you been you know
okay well let's step it up a little bit
then if you had to be haunted by an MCU
character who'd you pick
um
oh you know what I would say Spider-Man
why
because I would get to beat him up every
day
[Laughter]
such as Anthony Mackey
yeah I get this beat him up every day
yeah all right
easy
um I loved you and David Harbor together
in this I mean everyone the whole cast
is just so good uh but Anthony do you
think this is the closest we'll get to
seeing a Red Guardian Captain America
Showdown
uh probably I mean I'm you know I'm
taking it one day at a time with this
Marvel thing yeah um I don't know how it
works I haven't even started shooting
yet I might get fired I haven't read a
script I don't know what's going on uh
you know it's it's one day at a time
next thing you know Jay-Z might be
Captain America who knows I'm I'm taking
it one day at a time I love it um how do
you handle Jennifer Coolidge on set with
all that hair how was she
foreign she's great
um lots of fun
um it was funny he saw her hair before
you saw her so that was like that was
the cool thing but no she was great I
mean it was she was only there for like
a couple days so for maybe like three
days we just got to hang out with
Jennifer Coolidge and she was the best I
mean she was like telling the stories
and
um showing us her favorite like
Instagram accounts it was really yeah
and she was like six three with those
shoes though yeah she was very was she
really yeah she she was it was like
looking it was intense yeah
I love it well I really liked this movie
it was um like I said it was funny it
was really emotional too so congrats
guys
thank you so much